hey guys how's it going uh we're talking
really fast you know why because we're
going to be getting on a plane to
iceland in like two hours i don't even
know
what to do with myself i don't but what
i did do packed a knife okay
packed google glass got my phone i got
smart water guess what we're off the ice
all i have is a tissue because my
allergies are bad so yesterday we went
shopping to uh get this whole process
started and the problem with shopping
for winter things in spring is things
are either really on sale or you can't
find anything at all which seemed to be
the problem
get it off
okay
and also waiting last minute to shop for
things is also the problem
okay but we don't need this we need
those we can climb glaciers in i have
them you don't
i don't see any i'm so excited because i
was obsessed with the walter mitty movie
when i saw the preview in a theater in
like august i was like jenna we have to
see this and i hardly ever see
movies i was like yeah that's it i have
to see it and then we did in january we
saw it like this just came out of the
middle of nowhere like someone from fox
emailed me and said hey we're doing a
press tour do you guys want to come uh
oh yes with us to do things that walter
mitty did in the movie and i said yeah
yeah yeah yeah we're gonna have you guys
vote on things that you want to see us
do the first thing that we need you guys
to vote on and to tweet us is hashtag
midi dog sledding or hashtag midi
geocook puppies are food i like both of
them
i tweeted the other day asking if any of
you guys lived in iceland and i only
have a few responses so if any of you
guys do live there i know you're out
there because i see you in my google
analytics this is ground control to
major tom
that's the only part i know of his own
alright guys i'll see you in iceland
jenna will see you in iceland tweet us
all of the info will be in the
description make sure you guys tweet us
so we know what we have to do yeah
or food
thank you fox for making a dream come
true actually when we even saw the movie
i was like jenna we have to go to
iceland i know i was like we need to go
to iceland this is amazing like how are
we ever gonna go to iceland like it's
never gonna happen and guess what it's
happening to them oh i need this because
i gotta cut stuff i gotta cut the fish
that we're gonna true or if we are
geothermal cooking you're gonna have to
slice it up all right okay i love you
guys i'll see you soon
boom get out the way
you